welcome back to behind the screens a
weekly movies talk show with a new guest
each week and I'm so excited because
this week I have my lifelong crush Sean
William Scott in the building thanks for
coming thanks for having me this is my
first time meeting you but it's not your
first time meeting et I have something
to show you the alien wait where do we
meet the first time around show me this
was in 1999 and the premiere of American
Pie oh god yes watch this you know I
think that was the beauty of this movie
is that because everybody was kind of
like unknowns people relate more I mean
like everybody knew was stipler and
their high school I was my that was like
my goal everybody knew like a gym and I
think probably like created a lot more
doors or open a lot more doors for
actors that are you know might star
something that but for me this is like a
dream come true being here and that's
amazing yeah washing yeah I don't think
she wants me that's amazing that's so
sweet to see that playback it's funny
because my question to was like
something simple and I just went out no
it was like everybody in this movie is
relatively unknown like yeah how do you
sell a movie like this and now every
single person that's an American bite
like yeah there's not a single person in
that movie that isn't like that's so
huge huge like moment I've never seen
that clip you know and to see that I was
I mean that was a dream come true and be
it a premiere what was weird is that so
that was at Universal Studios and to get
to the theater I had to walk by the
store that I used to work at called
Scientific Revolution where I sold like
glow-in-the-dark stars and Bill Nye the
Science Guy puzzles and stuff
and that was only a year before I got an
American Pie so here I am walking to the
premiere walking by the store that I
used to work at and there's waving to
them being like hey guys no I didn't do
that but yeah it was pretty cool but it
got to be so insensitive
what at that time the member was like T
movies there was a whole team movie
cribs and teen comedies too and I mean
if if there had never been this kind of
resurgence of those movies I would never
have a career a lot of actors like now
they don't even really make comedies
know they don't know like if I'd pursued
acting now it would be really really
hard because they just don't they don't
make that many movies anymore
yeah but but goon we're here to talk
about the sequel last of the enforcers
but yes nice segue goon is your top
rated film that's like your well that's
not saying much most the movies that
I've done don't get good really that's
because there that's the comedy because
they're comedy companies typically don't
get you know good reviews yeah which I
really you don't make comedies really
for critics right it's one me not laugh
but yeah Adam Sandler wouldn't be
working if comedies were for critics
yeah you make whatever you feel like is
gonna be funny and they are you're right
they're like the first goon I remember
one of my family members is like dude
goons getting like good reviews that's a
new one for you thanks man
I remember like reading was like oh my
god just movie was getting really good
reviews it was really and people liked
the movie so much I remember just
walking around New York and people
stopping me and telling me they liked
the movie a lot so well we were thing
about doing the sequel for me it was
like let's not kill everybody's love for
the first one let's do a good sequel
hopefully great yeah I think we did I
mean that's that's what I was wondering
too because that has gunas such a cult
following too and it's kind of like one
of those like oh I didn't know this is
gonna be such a lightning in the bottle
thing so when it came to the sequel
getting pitched to you what was it about
it that you were like yeah absolutely
gonna do this and was there any
hesitancy to do that yeah well I was
nervous about doing a sequel because
there I mean how many Godfather twos are
there out there you know like typically
sequels can actually kill anything that
you really loved about the first movie
so I I didn't think the first movie lent
itself to doing another one but Jay
Baruchel who wrote
Rodan and he directed the second movie
he told me the idea and I really liked
it I thought like the idea basically for
the most part was to catch up with my
character and a lot of the the teammates
like six years later and you know my
character is married now and he's about
to become a father and and then seeing
all of the other guys and the team
older and like not as good and having to
really you know deal with the reality of
what life is gonna be like when hockey's
over and if that's all taken away from
you and how do you transition into a
different kind of day-to-day life and I
thought you know if we can make it funny
but it has that at its core like I liked
it a lot yeah I don't know this is like
a hot take or anything I actually liked
it better I did yeah that's awesome I
think it's really funny like right off
the bat like TJ Miller's in it now it's
so funny ready for that I'm surprised
that J hadn't gotten behind the camera
sooner because I feel like he is such
he's been collaborating with so many
people for so many years I'm surprised
it took him this long to for this to be
his like big feature directorial debut
it's true especially because he's always
wanted to direct and he's so bright and
and yeah I don't know why to be honest
because I'm glad it took him this long
because I got to be in his first movie
and the whole time I was I think you
know any any of the actors that worked
with him on the movie they you know that
we all think that like felt really lucky
to be in his first film and he's he's
great do you see yourself continuing to
collab with him and has that
conversation happened at all I tell Jay
to SEMATECH all the time like please
keep me in mind for your films yes he's
just yeah he's become a very close
friend and I he's he's just great so I'm
hoping to you know try to sneak my way
into his other movie your muse yeah yeah
but I I mean also with goon if people
like the audience really liked it you
know the sequel yeah he would be so fun
to keep working with all the guys again
and write find a way to keep telling
stories I'm even if it was like a
Netflix series and we focused on like
every episode you know I'm on a team
8-ball that could be fun yeah hey
no pitching it right now Netflix we're
doing it guys watching yeah do you ever
accidentally get punched in the face on
set because I feel like I would know I
accidentally punched some of the guys
did yeah yeah felt terrible though I
think the very in the sequel like the
very first fight that we shot first take
clocked one of the stunt guys and I was
like dude I'm an [ __ ] and he's like
trust me I've been punched harder I was
like it's not very nice but yeah it's
funny though but you know what my thing
is nothing to do the movie
I walk into stuff all the time every day
in just real life mm-hmm I always hit my
head I walk in something hits my head
every day what were you I have wardrobe
malfunctions constantly like how there
have been to weddings back-to-back that
I've gone to or something's gone
horribly wrong in front of a lot of
guests can you tell us sure I don't
think fine I don't think anybody cares
but I will tell I will tell you after
okay because yeah it's the thing okay so
you got your thing we all have our thing
yeah okay when I'm reading interviews
with you or watching interviews with you
it's like people always ask you if you
think you're typecast and that it's a
that's an annoying question to me
because I feel like yeah as many people
probably approach you daily with
something different every time
what do you think is like what's the
most common one that people say to you
well that I get that question because
I've pretty much played the same kind of
guy but it's also I mean think so though
Goines different to goons definitely
different like although I do play an
idiot but the truth is like one is
started off and I would get you know
things offered to me and comedies and
stuff like I I would most the part I've
most the time I would get offered like
the kind of wild guys there's so much
more fun to play yeah I can't really uh
now so don't see myself playing like the
boring kind of straight guy right like I
wanna play the guy who could say
anything he wants and kind of get away
with it and try to find a way to make
him loveable what you know so I don't
know if I've really maybe I've typecast
myself because this is the kind of
characters that I would prefer to play
if I was gonna do a comedy no wacky dude
yeah cuz I'm a weirdo Astron Koecher
said recently
that there was a dude where's my car to
which I feel like he maybe just made
that up
no I didn't I actually I had heard about
it like a while ago assisted I'm we were
hearing about it more but I remember
think I love Ashton like I haven't seen
him in so long and I had so much fun to
work with him and like it would be so
fun to work with him again I don't
remember I would see that movie in so
long but the title seriously dude
where's my car like I have to call my
agent and say like dude is there a
script out there because if it was weird
and dark might be funny yeah dude
where's my car was like one of my
favorite movies really yeah
now we have to do a sequel dude I
watched it like every day no you don't I
did I did
guess what I do I have it on a loop
constantly in your in your house I
actually have seven TVs in each room
with the loop different movies in each
one let me go in the old school room
bobbery just watch all my stuff like
hahaha goon last of the enforcers out
September first go check it out it's
very funny
I liked it better in the first I don't
really have my movies on a loop no I
don't know do that cut he died he died
really he definitely does